hello welcome a new edition of
las vegas ao in spanish natalia greets you
badly had one of the bands is
country for backs rather more iconic
known worldwide has just
announced a concert here in las vegas
I'm talking about camila the mexican band that
has  been in the music industry for
more than 15 years with and it's like everything changed
and I hug mel also to bring to
light this september 18 to the stage
of the tropicana hotel tickets for
those song collectors
because what I did and well they have a  cost
of 85 dollars and they are already on sale
well now the latin rock to the
iconic rock of the rolling stones who
will bring their no filter or no filter tour to
the legion station fans and followers of
this iconic band yes or yes they will feel this
satisfaction when  see this band on
november 6 this year this concert
will be the first of them is a pause
due to the pandemic tickets for this
concert go on sale in the morning
of es  Friday
and if you prefer to enjoy the
local entertainment outdoors hand
of ebay offers you its series of concerts
on the beach recently I had
told you about this musical series but
now I bring you an update and it is
that the pop group ninja degrees  has
just announced that they are joining this series of
concerts with their show being on
September 16 I remind you that on
August 28 the caifanes group will take the
stage and on September 18 the bronco group will
celebrate
Mexican independence day to buy your
tickets and the complete list of the
these artists that will
perform visit mandalay bay dotcom
and entertainment continue to arrive in
our city with the announcement of a
new show that will light up the las
vegas strip the acclaimed group ayuno mini
which began in the series of america's  got
talent will bring its show full of
music, dance and technology to the scratch
with its first act being on
August 26 tickets for this  show
are now on sale for more information
visit iluminet dotcom
and if you want to do something quieter
to do as a family I present
the musical adaptation of alice in
wonderland or the one i did in
wonderland' is complete with puppets and
much more  at the space in downtown
las vegas
this event will take place every
sunday afternoon during the month of august the
cost of tickets is only 25
dollars and they are already available at the
space
ld
dotcom well until your edition of
the  vegas nao in spanish thank you very much
for your attention see
you next week greets you natalia balseiro
[Music]